우리 또 윤재PD가 사이버 보보상 때문에 사실 우리 회사에 들어온 게
맞네
이분이 저를 뽑았는데 이분이 다른 팀으로 가시고
하선이 형도 게임 꽤나 하셨잖아요
하선님이 전사 멧돼지 딱 하고 뒤에서 계속 킬하고 있고
우리 윤재PD는 이 회사의 실세는 그럼 누구라고 생각하세요?
일단 GD라 눈치가 빨라요
백이윤이
그 형 정말 리스펙하고 잘하고 닮고 싶고 따라하고 싶고
그의 라인에 들고 싶은데
왜 이렇게 라인을 따져
원래 어디 라인이었어요?
아 형 라인이었죠
미안해 내가
형님
안녕하십니까 개미는 지금의 니니입니다
오늘은 구사보팀 용팀장과 윤재PD
운제PD라고도 부르죠
그리고 슈카월드의 영원한 PD
핫산형 머니코믹스 주식은 지금 라이브를 담당하는 정PD님
어서오세요
사보 관련해서 궁금한 것도 많고
어떻게 보면 역사 속으로 사라진
우리 사보가 부활 가능성이 있는지
저 뭐 평소 좀 조용히 회사하잖아요
생활했잖아요
팀이 사라진 이후로
우리 슈카님의 어떤 출입 경로에 자꾸 뭘 놔요
아 맞아요
샘플이나 좋은 제품들 받으면
제가 또 통로 자리잖아요
일부러 그쪽 자리에 잘 보이게 DP를 해놔요
아 다 전략이 있었어요?
그리고 제가 또 페이퍼 미리 써놓은 양식이 있으니까
그거를 계속 가져다 드리면서 환기시켜 드리고
그냥 가져다 드리는 게 아니고
키보드 위에 올려놔요
아 진짜?
우리 회사는 일이 없으면 본인이 일을 만들어야 돼
누가 일을 안 줘
우리 또 알상무님의 충신 우리 용팀장님 돈 많이 버셨습니까?
요즘에 착각을 많이 받으셨어요?
착각을 많이 받으셨어요?
착각 없어졌어
되게 뭐가 거절이 없고
아 원래 거절 안 해
클라이언트가 뭐 요청해도
아 예 할 수 있습니다 아 예
라식은 하더라고 그래도
아 라식 아 이거
그때가 또 그거예요
수험생 할인 기간 뭐 이런 거 있어가지고 좀 싸요
수험생이 아닐 때 어떻게 그 할인을 받아요
그리고 우리 핫싸녀
지난번에 핫 데뷔 이후에 반응이 미쳤어요
슈카님의 반응은 어떤 거였나요?
안 보신 거 같아요
자 그리고 우리 정피디님
우리 라이브 항상 선곡 누구냐
그 음악은 항상 어디서 그렇게 들으시나요?
제가 5층에 이제 근무하니까
가끔 오면은 노래가 틀어져 있더라고요
마샬 마샬 스피커
좋은 거
슈카님 가끔씩 지나가다가
야 팔자 팠다?
니가 회장님이야?
아 진짜로 가는 거야?
오늘 리얼로 가는 거야
최근 근황까지 한번 들어봤고
회사에 대해서 또 궁금해 하시는 분들도 많이 있고
그래서 우리 사이버보부상
지금 잠전 중단된 상태이지 않습니까
왜 없어졌나요 용팀장님
제가 이제 사실 회사 들어오기 전부터
커머스 이런 거 하면 좋겠다고 생각을 했었어요
왜냐면은 항상 이 영상을 뭔가
아 이건 디지털 1차 산업이다
아 바느질이다?
바느질이다
아 이거는 수익성이 좀 별로니까
물건이어도 팔아야 뭔가를
이걸 좀 수익을 올릴 수 있다
이렇게 맨날 얘기를 했었는데
왜냐면 경영학과고
사업적으로 그런 걸 잘 보고
이분이 들어오기 전부터 저한테
아 슈카월드에서 이거 팔면 잘 팔릴 거 같은데
맨날 그런 걸 보내요
맞아 기회가 있어서 막 보내고 그랬잖아요
직원도 아닌데
아무튼 근데 이제
또 다른 이제 수익사업을 해보자라고 하면서
이제 커머스를 하게 됐는데
단발성 할 땐 재밌었는데
레귤러화를 했었죠
근데 그러면서 약간 의도치 않게
이미지가 무슨 약간 물가 안정
약간 이렇게 된 거예요
그니까
이게 소비자들은
좋은데
우리는 거의 마이너스니까
거기 포커스가 꽂히면서
이게 약간 뭐지 우리 잔다르크
이렇게 돼버리면서
약간 그 다음 커머스에도
영향이 좀 있었다고 저는 생각을 했었거든요
무조건 최저가에 엄청 싸게 팔아야 되니까
그러니까 이게 이제는 비싸게 팔 수가 없는 거야
그러면서 이제 슈카님도 사실
거기 부담을 엄청 느끼는 거야
쿠팡보다 일단 몇백 원은 싸야 된다
근데 하다 보면 느끼는 게
진짜 쿠팡이 엄청 싸요
왜냐면 그 물량을 이겨낼 게 없어 사실상
쿠팡도 사실 그 안에
판매자 수수료 쿠팡 수수료
다 포함된 가격인데도
그 가격인 게 너무 신기할 정도였어
그 세 개를 또 아니까 새롭더라고요
규모의 경제 못 이기다
이게 너무 하면서 와닿는 거야
그래서 슈카님은 300만 팔로우 이렇게 있지만
거기서 이제 나오는 규모의 경제와
쿠팡의 규모의 경제는
절대 비교를 할 수가 없으니까
근데 거기서 만약에
우리가 예상한 판매량이 안 나와
그러면 우리 인건비도 안 나와요
조금만 실수하면 마이너스 바로 가버리는 거야
그치 실수하면 또 우리 돈으로
또 뭘 메꾸고 보내드리고 해야 될 게 있으니까
배송 문제 생겼어요
그러면 우리 잘못은 아니지만
우리 팬들한테 우리가 자랑스럽게 얘기를 한 거니까
우리 돈은 다 메꿔요
맞아요
그러니까 저희가 되게
처음 해보는 사업인데
사업이다 보니까
우리가 당연히 실수가 있었고
우리가 당연히 미숙했던 점은 있지만
그런 사실 구조적인 문제가 좀 있었죠
근데 우리가 사실 해보기 전에
어차피 이거 해도 안 되라고 하기보다는
그래도 해보고 실패를 하든 성공을 하든
잘 되면 엄청 좋은 거니까
그래서 진짜 사보팀이 고생이 진짜 많았죠
그런 얘기도 있어요
근데 안 하면 안 하는 거지
머니코믹스에서 왜 또 팍 팀장이 나와서
너무 아쉬운 제품들이 많아요
그리고 이게 사업 부서 마인드는 또 저런 데
콘텐츠를 만드는 저희 쪽 입장에서는
사실 플레이어 분들도 그렇고
피디분들도 되게 욕심이 많으세요
하고 싶은 게 되게 많고
근데 이게 저희가 예술을 하거나 노는 게 아니잖아요
돈을 벌어야 되는데
그럼 어떻게든 돈을 벌어야 되니까
우리 한번 그러면 이런 조합으로도 해보고
저런 조합으로도 해보자
그러면서 약간 시도를 했던 의도가 있었어요
맞아요 맞아요
근데 사실 슈카님이 어떻게 보면 좀 멀리 보시는 거죠
우리가 단기적으로 돈을 얼마 벌고 이게 아니고
장기적으로 좀 신뢰를 쌓으면서
우리 구독자분들한테 실망을 드리지 않는
그런 방향으로 달려다 보니까 쉽지는 않았다
하지만 정말 두 분이 고생이 많으셨고
은재피디가 사이버 보부상 때문에
사실 우리 회사에 들어오게 된 건데
맞네 맞네
두 분이 저를 뽑았는데
이 분이 다른 팀으로 가시고
난 라인이 사라졌어요
그러면 지금 말 그대로 낙동원 은재형이 됐는데
지금 슈카 친구들에서 생존 전략이 있다면
일단 제가 편집을 요즘 배우고 있고요
연출이랑 카메라 장비까지만 조금 다를 줄 알면
혼자서 좀 모셔놓고 할 수 있는 포맷을 하나 개발해서
할 수 있지 않을까
본인이 출연해서?
그 정도도 되고요
왠지 루시아 시즌2가 생각나는
저희 같은 빌드홈을 지금
방송 출연하고 가족분들이나 여자친구나 주변 반응 어때요?
연락 오죠
항상 제 방송을 어머님이나 일가 친척들이 다 보세요
카톡 자료 하나 있긴 한데
어떡해 감동이다
진짜 모니터링 다 하시나봐
피드백도 주시고 더 열심히 해야죠
더 얼굴을 비춰야 되네 어떻게 보면
그렇죠 그래야 되는데 좀 연습도 필요한 것 같고
다른 사람들 백이웃님 너무 잘하잖아요
너무 잘해
질투해
되게 견제하다고
잘하는데 잘해 잘하긴 하지만
호적수로 인정한다 이런 느낌
잘해 훨씬 잘해 훨씬 잘하는 거 인정
아니 근데 댓글에 아니 PD가 왜 웃겨야 해
심지어 근데 사실 PD도 아니야
솔직히는 편집할 줄 몰랐어요 여기 와서
광고 마케팅 이런 포지션이었는데
지금 이제 프리미어 어도비를 배우고 있다는 거죠
멋있어요 모니터들 두 개 세 개 깔아 놓고
보라색 창 띠 이렇게 해 놓고
아직 고생 안 했구나
아 좋습니다
저희가 또 주신 얘기 또 안 할 수가 없잖아요
일단은 우리 핫선이 형님이 지난번에
이제 3전
저와 함께 20만 원에 올인한 용자가 되었는데
일단은 그 전에 어깨 아직 걸고 계신가요?
아 그렇네
3전을 어제 한 20% 정도는
아니 왜냐면 안 가
더 가는 애들이 더 많아
그러니까 뭐냐면 제가 3전 친구를 버린 건 아니에요
얘는 아직 내 자식이야
근데 엄마가 돈 벌어올 테니까
엄마가 돈 벌어올 테니까 조금만 기다려
그 바람필 때 심리가 보통 이래요
내가 너를 사랑하지 않는 건 아니야
하지만 다른 데서
입 뒤에 들어오는 게 있어
그럼 뭐 이렇게 밥 한 번 먹을 수는 있는 거잖아
우리 핫선이 형 계좌 한번 보여주시면
일단 저번 출연 때 이거 찍어달라 그래가지고
그때 켜고 오늘 처음 켜는 거예요
아 진짜?
네이버 카카오 페이 같은 경우는
저거는 좀 잘라버리면 안 돼요?
저거는 공모주 때 산 거예요
근데 그러면은 몇 주 못 받았을 텐데
한 세 주?
그러니까 그만큼 제가 안 팔아요
아니 지난번 방송 못 보신 분들 계시겠지만
OTP를 장롱해서
그러다가 이제 오랜만에 주식 계좌 한 3년 만에
OTP 공인인증서 만료됐더라고요
아니 근데 사실 슈카월드 편집을 하시니까
예전에 효성중공업 관련해서 브랜디드 컨텐츠 할 때
이 친구가 그때 광고 담당자라 가지고
너무 좋아 보여서 샀잖아요 영화 나가고 나서
근데 왜 효성중공업 그거를 직접 편집을 하셨잖아요
효성으로 우리 영팀장이 개꿀빵 거는 이제 들었죠
코멘트 하겠습니다
뭐야
말하러 나온 방송에서 말 안 하고 코멘트 할 거면은 뭐...
노켓 멘트 하겠습니다
가끔 우리 사장님이 영팀장한테 살짝 자극받아요
그 친구가 그렇게...
300만 유튜버를 지은다는 남자?
그 친구가 그거를 그렇게 했었어? 이러면서 약간
한 번씩 영팀장 얘기는 하더라고요
누군가의 자산에 대해서 얘기를 하는 걸 처음 들었어요
아 그러니까 거의 기관 아니야 기관?
야 아이씨 무슨...
아 알겠습니다 그럼 우리 탓선이 형은 큰 변화는 없고
놔두면 오른다에 어떻게 보면 표본인 거네요
저 같은 경우는 얘기를 해주면 좋아요
저는 남의 말을 되게 잘 들어요
사기 전날도
그치 삼전 부흥회 때
부흥회 때 우리 거의 할렐루야 미쳤단 말이야 새벽에서
그때 니네랑 다짐을 했던 게
우리가 사는 건 오를 거라고 생각해서 사는 게 아니다
우리는 자산에 적어도 여유분의 거의 대부분을
여기에 넣었다는 이 행위가 중요하다
근데 왜 20% 팔으셨어요?
어떻게... 말을 안 해
아니 그러니까 좋은데 더 좋은 애들이 있어
얘랑 뭐 사귀는 것도 아니고
아 많이 발전했네
안 돼 아 너무 똑똑해지고 계셔
그럼 어떻게 맨날 마이너스 인생으로 살 수가 없잖아
왜냐면 나도 재밌게 하려면 막 잡주에 물리고
나도 그렇게 해서 방송을 뽑고 싶어요
근데 그게 약간 지금 진심이 되는 순간
진짜 현생이
멍청해지는 것 같아
제 계좌에 대한 얘기로 시작을 했으니까
용팀장 같은 사람이 팔라고를 해줘야 돼요
나 어제 팔았는데
그럼 어제 공시를 안 해요 이 형
그래서 세 명이서 그럼 동원결의하고
어제 20% 팔고 어제 팔고
말을 하라고 말을
말을 안 해주셔
할 때는 되게 적극적으로 말씀해주시는데
셀 할 때는 아무 소식 없다가
그거 아직도 갖고 있어
너 내 말 되게 잘 듣는구나
이거는 근데 나 백윤한테만 이래
보통 일반적으로는 혹시나 이 사람 돈이 이르면
내가 괜히 미안하잖아요
그러니까 원래 주인 얘기 한 번도 안 했어요
그러다가 이제 백윤이 얘기하다 보니까
서로 말 듣고 투자해도
이러도 원망하지 않는다
나 오른쪽에 앉아 있는데
처음 입사했을 땐 되게 챙겨주시는 거예요
뭐 한글 파일이고 다 알려주시다가
백윤이 입사하고 나서 왼쪽 앉으니까
나에 대한 존재감은
나 이렇게 얘기하면 너무 미안하잖아
사사로운 그런 이야기 있잖아
나 라식 알아봤어
옷 샀어
머리 했어
매직 했어
그거 다
내가 가운데
그러면 우리 용 팀장님은 최근에
삼성전자 사실 어제 한 3분의 1 팔고
그게 판 이유가
제가 그나마 이제 알성문님을 많이 따르면서
몇 가지 룰을 항상 세우고 있었는데
그 중 하나가
불확실성이 있을 때는 일단 피하자였어요
그래서 그거 좀 팔고 그걸로 이제 하이닉스를 샀죠
그 외에 예를 들면 한미반도 어차피 맨날 얘기하지만
저는 이제 그런 데에다가는 잘 못 넣겠어요
그러니까 삼성전자 하이닉스 완전 주도주
거기 차라리 나는 큰 포트를 칠지
그나마 아는 거에 실는 거지
모르는 거에 못 넣고
그래서 그냥 하이닉스 사고
나머지는 그때 알성문님 호텔실라 얘기할 때
아니 거의 알성문님 부셀이야
슈카님한테는 슈카님 5분만 5분만
아니 이거 너무
막 들어와서 얘기하라고 얘기하자고
알성문님한테는
오른손 왼손 포갠 다음에
이렇게 이렇게
진짜 이 회사가 엄청 수평적인 회사인 줄 알았어요
가장 수직적인 거
숫자로 인격을
숫자나 인격이지
그럼 우리 용 팀장은
삼성전자 한 60% 하이닉스 30%
나머지 5%도 뭐 호텔실라 하나 갖고 있고 지금
기분 나쁜데?
그러니까
자 우리 기분 나쁜 우리 정피디 계좌 한번 보시죠
오 수익률 꽤 좋네요
원케이크 거 광고 끝나고 바로 둘 다 들어갔었는데
되게 생각보다 결과가 잘 나와서
또 하나 더 있죠 계좌가
어 슈퍼 365 계좌
진짜 충신이야
아니 수요일 방송만 끝나면
그렇게 핸드폰을 주고장차
데스북 나가시는데 뭐 가든지 말든지
혹시 그 방송 나갈 때 컷 전환이 느려지면
약간 이러고 있는 거 아니야?
그냥 그런 줄 아십시오
근데 우리 방송 보면 잃지는 않는다
어 네 그거는 네
아니 확실히 알성문님이 괜찮아요
그래프 보고 어 요거 막 기관이면 샀다 이랬는데
어 왜왜왜
그거 주봉이야
뭔데 뭔데
요 찾았다
오 너 이거 사고싶다
다음날 쏘는 거야
다음날 시작하자마자 8% 올라오고 시작했어
8%에 맞춰서 들어갔다가 2% 손실법도 나왔어요
찻산형도 게임 꽤나 하셨잖아요
그러면 슈카님이랑 예를 들면 스타 같은 거 할 때
접대도 해드리고
일부러 저들이고
접대를 안 하려고 대결하는 게임 잘 안 하고
그럼 예를 들면 와우 같은 거 하더라도
슈카님이 이제 전사 멧돼지 딱 하고
네 넌 내 물약이다
뒤에서 계속 킬하고 있고
그거 힘들어가지고 못하겠더라고요
그럼 우리 운제 PD
아 최초 공개
지금 주로 어디에 투자를 하셨나요
일을 하면서 하나하나 종목 그렇게 들어가는 건
너무 어렵고 힘들고 시간도 없고 그래서
매일매일 한 주씩 두 주씩 사는 거
모기 모기
그냥 월급 들어오면은
1, 2년 전에는 미국 주식 정말 핫했잖아요
나스닥 100 S&P 500 이런 걸로 하다가
작년에 전부 다 셀하고
커버드 콜로 사자
배당 따박따박 주니까
포지션 안 겹치게
국산 것도 포함해가지고
4개 5개 락 걸어놓고
나머지 한 700만 원 정도는 이제
용호님이 전달해 주시는 그 자료로
했는데
결론적으로 돈을 벌었어요
좋아요 이게
사라라는 그 정보는 정말 잘 주세요
판매하는 그거는 타이밍을 절대 알려주지 않아요
그때 건설 ETF
그거 사라고 하셔서
제 개인 투자 의지로 샀잖아요
그다음에 형님이 해외 가셨어
그래 그게 발살나잖아
그래서 나는 오히려 거기서 마이너스였어요
다 촬영 끝나고 공용 공간에서
팔 거야? 팔 거야? 이러다가
팔자 이러고 팔았는데
다시 급등했어요
그렇게 둘이서 팔까? 하고 있을 때
이 둘은
가만히 가만히 있었어
여기가 흔히 나오지
전 그렇게 폭락을 연일로 했잖아요
그때조차도 용팀장 원망하지 않았어요
말하지 않는 게 더 원망스러운 거야 지금
그래도 저는 결국 플러스가 돼서
벌어서 탈출했잖아요
그걸 캡쳐해서
아 형님 너무 감사합니다
하니까 그때 백이윤이 밑에
와 짱짱짱 막 이랬잖아요
형 그렇게 난 이렇게 한다니까
그러니까 둘 다 진짜
이러도 원망하지 않는데
나한테 사소한 거 얘기 안 해주고
쉬실 것만 있었던 거야
써주지 않아
이게 더 슬픈 거야 이 두 사람은
대체 용호는 어떤 사람 어떤 애가
지금 사실 하나 왕건이가 남아있잖아요
부동산
퇴직연금
생애 최초로 여자친구가 라디오 광고를 딱 듣고
여기 검색해보니까 좋은 거 같다
우와
우리 승장은 은재PD였다
근데 왜 이렇게 열심히 살아요
근데 형님들만큼 비상하지 않잖아요
제 계좌는 비상이긴 한데
비상
아 다음은
아 쟤 좀 민망스럽네요
아 이거를 좀 공개하기가 싫은 게
쟤 컨셉이 있다 보니까
뭐야?
아 뭐야?
뭘 샀다고 말하냐 말씀드리기가 어려운 게
저도 사실 샀다 팔았다를 좀 꽤 하는 편이고
계좌가 하도 많아가지고
너 갖고 있다면서 뭐 왜 또 없다 그러냐
한데 사실 그게 또 다른 계좌에 들어가 있고
복잡한 경우가 많아서 그렇지
좀 양해해 주시면 감사하겠습니다
첫 번째 계좌가 장투 계좌
요거 이제 내 눈에 흙이 들어오기 전까지는 안 팔아 계좌인데
바로 미출 20% 정리라고 그러는 건 뭐야
눈에 흙이 몇 번 들어갔는데
너 흙 뿌렸어요?
이제 여러분들 잘 아시는 뭐 하이닉스 뭐 삼성전자
궁금한 게
지금 다 플러스잖아요
그러면은 손절을 한 거예요?
아 그치 여러분들이 좋은 것만 보시는 거예요
왜냐면 제가 사실 손절을 몇 차례 했어요
뭐 여러분 잘 아시는 네이버라든지
그래서 사실은 제가 지금 여기 보면 다 플러스만 보이지만
번 게 별로 없다는 게
그때 이미 마이너스가 너무 많이 났기 때문에
자 그리고 연금저축 계좌는
니케이 저거
상무님이 니케이 쇼트 얘기하실 때마다 얼마나 우스웠을까
그때마다 샀죠
상무님 덕분에 둘 다 돈을 버네
상무님 덕분에 돈을 좀 벌었어요
말을 들었어
한명은 알바꼴로써
그리고 제가 한 번 방송 때
소개해 드린 게 비상금 계좌
그 토스인가 그걸로 보니까
제가 가지고 있는 계좌 다 보여주더라고요
평단이 17만 원대에 7주 밖에 없더라고 7주
근데 저게 지금 한 780만 원이네요
근데 저거 안 왔으면 팔았었겠지
아 그치
그니까 숨겨져 있길 잘했어
근데 저게 요즘에는 카카오페이 아니면
뭐 뱅크샐러드 이런 걸로도 다 찾을 수 있는데
어떻게 몰라요?
그러니까 지금까지 안 했다는 것도 좀 신기하긴 한데
난 안 했어요
그러니까 있다니까
OTP를 얘기하시는 분은
이런 걸 관리하기 전에는
계좌를 하나
만들고 여기서 쭉 거래를 하다가
다른 계좌로 갑자기 어떠한 이유로 가서
근데 이게 진짜 슬픈 사연이 있어요
이게 보기가 싫은 거야
그래서 이제 내가 좋은 것마다
이제부터 새 출발해야지 이러고
아 그럴 때마다 계좌를 하나 더 만들고
그러고 이제 플러스 나면
오 좋다 좋다 마이너스 또 또
마지막 계좌는
제가 얼마 전에 니뉴쌤으로 나무 증권 광고 했잖아요
그래서 저기 천만 원을 넣었는데
요즘에 장이 좋았잖아요
저렇게 이제 수익이 잘 났고
그리고 사실 여러분들 기억나실지 모르겠는데
투자 토론회라고 있었어요
배당육첩반상이라고 해가지고
배당 많이 받는 주식을
여기서 알아서 운용을 해준다
뭐 바꿔준다
이렇게 해가지고
제가 그때부터
그때가 한 작년 9월이었거든요
거기에 따박따박 돈을 넣고 있어요
그래서 수익이 나더라고요
그래도 광고 주신 분들 거를 잘 썼더니
저렇게 수익이 잘 났다 라는 걸 보여드리기 위해서
그래서 여러분들 저에게 광고를 주시면
또 파도록 하겠습니다
현대차가 없네요
아까 있었어요
호재를 찾는 분이 한 분 계신다고 기억이 나가지고
현대차 최근에 저도 좀 샀어요
그분에게 죄송해가지고
그분을 또 한 번 모셔보려고 지금 연락을 드렸는데
이틀째 지금 연락이 안 오고
그러면 우리 계좌를 한 번 탈탈 털어봤고
여러분들이 또 우리 슈카친구들에 대해서
굉장히 궁금한 점이 많아요
우리 슈카친구들에 대한 질문을
제가 몇 개를 좀 가져왔는데
슈카친구들 직원이 되려면 이런 게 필요하다
필요한 덕목이 있다면
우리 운재 PD 한 번 얘기해 주실까요?
특별한 직무를 뽑잖아요
그 직무에 딱 맞는 스킬들
그 경력이 요즘은 좀 확실하게 핏해야 되는 거 같아요
경력으로?
나는 잘 모르겠는데
나는 다 잘해야 된다고 생각하는데 오히려
그건 기본이고 내가 그걸 몰라
그러면 밤새로 공부해와서 할 수 있어야 돼요
그게 맞는 거 같아요
이미 해당 기능을 보유하고 있으면 당연히 좋아요
그런 장점 이외에도
솔선수범도 있고 행동력도 있고 욕심도 있고
근데 이게 약간 조소기업의 특징이에요
다 잘해야 돼 열심히 해야 되고
그러니까 이게 중소기업이 사람 뽑기가 힘들다는 게
잘하는 사람 당연히 뽑고 싶은데
또 그 잘하는 사람은 대기업 가고 싶어 하고
또 이게 약간
악순환인 거 같은 생각도 좀 있어요
그래서 우리 회사에서 일하는 게 정말 개꿀은 아니다
장단점이 명확하다라고 정의할 수 있어요
일 좋아하시는 분들은 확실히 좋은 회사고
빡세고 많이 받을래 그런 사람이랑은 좀 맞고
나는 워라벨파야 그럼 좀 안 맞죠
이거 보신 분 중에 유튜브 업계에 계신 분들도 있을 텐데
유튜브 업계는 애초에
저는 워라벨 없다고 생각해요
기본적으로 욕심이 있으면
그리고 저는 개인적으로 놀 때 놀고 일할 때 일하는 사람이 좀 맞는 거 같아요
저희가 사실 되게 재밌는 것 같아요
재미를 항상 추구하다 보니까
가끔 이제 다른 회사 예전 회사 다닐 때도 보면
일할 때 놀라고 하는 사람들이 계시는데
그러지 않고 일할 때는 다들 집중해서 하고
재미뽑을 때는 또 재미뽑아주는 그런 모습들이 저는 보기가 좋더라고요
우리 운제PD는 이 회사의 실세는 그럼 누구라고 생각하세요
일단 쥐띠라 눈치가 빨라요
확다운 방식으로 우리 업무가 이루어지잖아요
근데 유일하게 바텀업 하는 업무가 있어요
그런 존재가 바로 백이윤이에요
이 기획 콘텐츠 회사로서 기획, 연출, 스케쥴,
캐주얼링, 편집을 다 담당할 수 있는
그 유일한 임무를 할 수 있는 게 PD 직군인데
심지어 경력직이고 그는 개인 채널을 운영하고 있고
유튜버였잖아요 원래
실력도 아주 충주래요
그리고 그는 그 안에 자기를 집어넣어요
또 그게 질투 포인트인 것 같은데
그러니까 나는 질투하지 않았던 거 아니야
그 형 정말 리스펙하고 잘하고 닮고 싶고 따라하고 싶고
그의 라인에 들고 싶은데
왜 이렇게 라인을 따져
원래 어디 라인이었죠
형 라인이었죠
미안해 내가
형님 최근 머니코미스 채널의 콘텐츠를 유심히 보시는데
대부분 그가 기획했으며
그가 연출을 하며
그의 번뜩이는 아이디어들이 많은 조회수를 이뤄요
그래서 편집을 배우고 있는 게
아 나도 뭔가 나만의 기획을 해서 틈을 찾아보자
우리 기훈 PD를 이기기 위해
앞으로 내가 회사에서 이렇게 살아남겠다
일단 라인을 찾아야 될 것 같은데요
자꾸 라인을 찾아야 돼
그는 니니 라인이에요 확실하게
일단 니니님 라인을 타기에는 백윤을 이길 수 없어
그렇다면 알상무님인데
상무님은 라인 생기는 걸 거추장스러워 하죠
맞아 맞아
그치 그치 그치
산전수전 공중전 다 겪은 분이
은퇴하기 전에 잠깐 소일거리 하는 느낌으로 계세요
슈 라인은?
슈카님은 일단 오후 3시 이후에 오시니까
그걸 말하면 안 돼
말하면 안 돼
그거 비밀이야 그거는
아 몰라
그러니까 벌써 잘렸잖아
벌써 잘렸어
근데 이게 우리 윤재 PD님이
오래 안 돼서 그럴 수도 있는데
어 그래 조금 더 됐잖아요
보면은 경제에서도 이제 보이지 않는 손이라는 게 있잖아요
어 그래
딱 봤을 때 보이는 손과 보이지 않는 손이 있어요
보이는 손 보이지 않는 손
생각해보면 슈카님 앞자리 바로 옆자리
사내의 모든 방향을 이쪽에서 다 아시고
이쪽은 이제 직접적으로 가서 빠따치고
우리 최근에 식비 제한이 생겼잖아요
그동안의 큰 사랑으로 식비 제한 없이 잘 썰 수 있었죠
네
근데 이제 인원이 늘어나면서 생기는 건 솔직히 당연하다고 생각해요
어 그렇지 술술 나오는 술술 그냥
그동안 저희가 큰 사랑 받았던 것이고
그럼에도 불구하고 이만큼의 금액을 배정해 주신 거는
참 감사한 일이다
내부적으로 감사하다
하지만 그럼에도 불구하고
조금은
강남
이럴 때의 물가에 비하면은
조금은 생각하면서 써야 된다
아까 지배적
근데 아까 뭐 민심을 좀 솔직하게 듣고 싶었는데
뭐 살짝 좀 사리는 거 같기도 하고
아 아직 시행한 지 뭐 이틀째 3일째니까
대부분은 뭐 올 게 왔다
맞아
올 게 왔어요
그건 진짜 맞아
맞아 어쩔 수 없어
일단은 이제 그런 공지하는 입장에서
조금 항변을 잠깐만 드리자면은
그 취지예요
이제는 생각을 좀 하자 보자 한번
그게 얼마나 어떻게 애로사항이 있고 고충이 있으니까
어떻게 수정을 해야 되는지 보자라는 측면에서
그걸 보려면
그 정도까지는
그렇지
제한이 걸려요
맞아 맞아
뭐 그런 느낌이에요
아 근데 뭐 간식도 그랬잖아요
처음에 한 달 뭐 20만 원 했다가
어 3일 만에 끝나네
이러면 이제 조금씩 늘려가는 거지
그렇죠 그럴 수밖에 없죠
이것도 해보면서 이제 하는 거잖아요
맞아 맞아 맞아 맞아
이 방송 뭐야 운영 회의야
근데 웃긴 거는 이 방송으로 5,100명이나 모으고 있어
지금 이 초소 회의를
약간 사내 사냥 회의를
감사합니다
저희 사
저희 노조
아잉
노조?
어 노조가 얘 새꺄죠?
아니야 아니야
아 근데 이런 얘기가 저는 제일 재밌는 거 같아요
이제 마지막으로 머니코믹스가
개편을 앞두고 있어요
어떻게 개편을 자주 합니까?
아 그 살아야 되니까
예상만큼 성과가 나오지 않아서?
유튜브같이 변화무쌍한 시장은
그니까
내가 봐도 봐도 죽여요
아 죄송합니다
이게 개편이라는 게 열심히 어떻게 해보려고 했는데
출연자 이슈도 있고 물리적으로 해보니까 이게 쉽지가 않다
우리도 뭐 방송 많이 해서 돈 많이 벌면 좋죠
여러분들도 볼 거 많으면 재밌고 좋은데
우리가 방송국이면은 뭐 매일매일 돌아가고 해도 되는데
유튜브는 또 그런 식으로 운영이 좀 어렵더라고요
또 그런 의견도 되게 많았어요
아 너무 볼 게 많아서 구독 취소합니다
너무 필요합니다
막 이런 것도 있고
각자 생각이 다 다르다 보니까
이거를 저희가 100% 만족을 시켜드리기가 좀 어려워요
저희 출연자들의 어떤 컨디션도 사실 생각해야 되고
길게 가려면
그러다 보니까 사실 저희가 조금
이시도 저시도 하는 게 조금 있기는 한데
여러분들이 또 너그럽게 봐주시면 좋을 것 같고
근데 결국은 이걸 더 가냐 안 가냐의 판단은 결국 조회수잖아요
그렇죠
냉정하게 조회수가 모든 걸 말해줍니다
맞아 맞아
뭐 말 나온 김에
아 코믹스 좀 이렇게 됐어
됐으면 좋겠다 뭐 각자 의견이 있을까요?
지금은 사실 경제 관련 분들이 오셔서
재밌는 거를 뽑아내는 거에 많이 집중이 돼 있었다고 생각을 하거든요
이제는 좀 경제가 아닌 분들을 데리고 와서
경제 쪽으로 끌고 가는 것도 재밌겠다 싶어서
연예인 분들이든 아니면 좀 인플루언서 분들이든 하면 재밌지 않을까?
구체적으로 그 프로미스9을 얘기를 하시던데
거기까지 가는 거예요?
뭐 아이돌 얘기하신 거 다 얘기해봐요?
우리 핫산형도 사실 하실 말씀 많으실 것 같아요
코믹스 채널을 사람들이 사랑해 주시고
니니가 거기서부터 발전하기 시작하고 했던 어떤 이유가 있을 거잖아요
그 이유로 돌아가야 한다는 게 제 생각이에요
어느 정도 이제 많이들 사랑해 주셔서 규모가 생겼고
사람도 늘어났고 할 수 있는 일이 많아졌고 선택지가 많아졌는데
슈카월드 같은 경우는 10년 전부터 지금까지 별로 바뀐 게 없잖아요
코믹스는 굉장히 많이 바뀌었죠
바뀌다는 게 나쁜다는 건 아니에요
나쁘다는 건 아니지만 너무 많이 바뀐 거 같은 생각도 들어요
그러니까 이게 진짜 사람들이 의견이 다 다른 것 같아요
진짜 다 달라요
왜냐하면 여기는 또 연예인이나 인플루언서들 모셔야
이게 채널이 좀 더 클 수 있다
근데 사실 또 근본을 원하시는 분들은
누가 나오고 누가 나와도 그냥 근본 조합이 제일 재밌다
또 이러시는 분들도 있고
그래서 어떻게 보면 일단은 좀 청취하는 거에 또 의의가 있는 거 같습니다
운재 PD님 또 어떻게 생각하세요?
초심자들한테도 좀 잘 알려줄 수 있는?
지금은 너무 고인 증권 방송이 됐구나
조금 공부하고 봐야죠 솔직히 말해서
요즘 영어 약자가 조금 슬슬 나오기 시작했어요 너무 어려워요
그거는 좀 필요하다
근데 약간 비슷한 게 제 친구들도 처음에는 제가 나오니까 재밌게 보다가
아 이거 좀 너무 어렵다는 거야
계속 쭉 이제 우리를 보시는 분들은 따라서 같이 공부가 되는데
그냥 아예 오늘 처음 구독했어
근데 막 어려운 주식 얘기를 막 계속 하고 있어
그러면은 또 그분들은 아 여기 어려운 주식 채널이네가 된다 보니까
근데 또 여기를 맞추려면 옛날 사람들 아 그 유치해 또 이러니까
이게 어려워 힘들어요
그러니까 여러분들 이상한 질문을 한다고 해서 뭐라 하지 마세요
챙겨드리는 겁니다
계속 리셋해야 돼요
근데 예전에 알상무님이 했던 얘기 중에 난 그게 되게 와닿았던 게
우리 방송에서 이런 게 많이 나오잖아요? 우리 방송에서 이런 게 많이 나오잖아요?
그래서 가장 어려운 단어는 PER이어야 된다
왜냐면 사실 슈카쌤만 봐도 그게 어떻게 보면 이 채널에 한 단계 점프업을 시켜준 콘텐츠였는데
그것만 봐도 어려운 단어가 하나도 안 쓰이거든요
근데 저는 그 정도는 되어야 된다
그래서 저는 한편으로는 정PD님이랑 비슷한 의견인 게
여기서 파일을 늘리려면 결국은 더 대중한테 나가야 되거든요
그렇죠
근데 저는 그런 것도 괜찮아요
지금 니니쌤 콘텐츠도 그 멍청 포지션을 지금 잡는 거는 오케이
근데 그
포지션을 잡는 거라고 생각하는
이게 아는 거랑 설명하는 게 다르기 때문에
그게 진짜 슈카님의 시험이니까
신이 주신 재능인 게 대체자가 없어
옛날에 슈카님 친구분이 말씀하신 것도 있고
저도 동의하는데요
슈카님은 워낙 달변이시다 보니까
말로 하는 그냥 아무거나 했어도 잘 되셨을 것 같아요
그 중에 제가 생각했을 때 이거 다음으로 가장 미래의 가능성이 있었던 거는
제 생각엔 목사예요
장난 아니었을 거예요 진짜
오늘 개미는 지금 역대급으로 길게 했는데
아 근데 이거 재밌는데요?
사내 회의를 방송으로
저는 편했어요
자 개미는 지금은
또 새로운 모습으로 한번 여러분들께 다가오도록 하겠고
우리 시청해주신 여러분들 감사합니다
또 오겠습니다 안녕
감사합니다